this is something that I make you want
to slap your mama you know I know what
you mean
live in direct from Hollywood it's feast
or hunger squad we're gonna be traveling
all over Southern California we're gonna
go to one soul food but you eat there
soldier yeah that's all food joint
they're gonna tell us their favorite
soul food joy and then you follow that
trail and go on and on and on until you
find the best soul food in Los Angeles
can I get an amen amen
perfect let's go gonna say that all day
are we gonna judge these places by the
way you feel in your soul
I got waiver yeah and then the last one
last one comfort comfort can I get an
amen amen
about to pull up to the spot the boiler
you know here's what up 30% Asian out
here Stephen did some Wikipedia on the
way today
we're on this like soul food adventure
and we're trying to find the best soul
food in whole LA it's gonna be pretty
tough to beat yours to find out you're
an Asian dude I'm an Asian dude how did
you get in the soul food business just
fell in love with New Orleans decided to
try to bring it over to Southern
California he doesn't really know much
about soul food what do you think he's
gonna learn today it's all about the
Trinity spices like you know the truck
yeah all right let's do this
this is what I got so far we've got
oysters on the half-shell we've got
shrimp po-boy we've got gumbo and then
we've got some bacon-wrapped delicious
looking morsels over here all right I
don't eat this let it done you're going
very much better than Italy that is
fresh I guess thought man I'm in okay
let's do the pan house signature dish
going down the hatch that right there
that's so cool as per the huge I'm
eating too much and we have two more
stops I'm gonna cook hauling off here no
way you know as far as comfort goes I'm
feeling warm flavors exploding all over
the place they're getting they're
getting a foreign flavor no no you're
not saying flavor right it's way above
us I'm gonna get one before we still
have two more places to go well I'll
give it a five
that's tray of five I mean when we
talked about the Trinity today when
you're not eating cold food at your own
spot have you heard of any good places
in LA that have really good salt it's a
great spot called mama slow down on Pico
in LA back to Los Angeles we're going to
mama soul all right guys ready to go
mamas all yeah you okay I'm fine
I feel very full I feel ready to eat
another two rounds I'm ready for some
like mac and cheese though I got all
right so we finally made it to mama
Seoul we have star here our Nicias that
we do are all natural so our meats have
no pesticides no hormones and we work
with local farmers for our produce so
we're very proud of that
I took the yummiest things and soul food
and put it all together
mac and cheese yams that I love black
eyed peas that I grew up with so its
flavors from all over
let's just dig in okay oh I got my start
as a soul food ranch yeah I love that
there's a turkey leg floating in the
collars beans remind me of something I
don't know what it is but it's comfort
oh wait this Corvettes got a little
sticky top don't interrupt the woman
she's eating can't make any judgments
yeah I paint the catfish though there's
not one thing reading here is the same
as anything we ate the last giant yet
it's still salt oh you forget this so
foods kind of a pretty big wide variety
of stuff I literally feel like I'm in my
own canaries kitchen do you havenít want
named canary yeah that's amazing
you're comfortable nothing at home 4.50
I'm flavor
no Bazar around are you convinced Freddy
you don't have to go back to Virginia
offense Oh Freddy I don't feel like this
was like a family reunion experience
love comfort good food good vibe got to
keep going
look alive Steve come on we don't have
time for your shenanigans no I can't go
anymore I quit all right I'm getting the
car Freddy you living in the car get in
the car all right so we are headed to
chef Marilyn's on Crenshaw Boulevard so
we are here with chef Marilyn of Chef
Marilyn's be chef Marilyn
27 years you still love it you wake up
every day excited I love it I work seven
days a week I wake up every day and the
fulfillment part is that people love the
food favorite thing on your on your menu
people love everything so food is good
and it's from the heart that's probably
the easiest way to define from the heart
so we got mac and cheese yeah
black-eyed peas spinach smothered
chicken all right guys our last stop
from the soul food tour this is a
takeout only joint so we're eating in
the back of the car I have to say I
think this catfish is better than mom no
way longevity after like 20 minutes are
so good way to taste it the cornbread is
really getting me excited the crispy
edges
I love crispy edges it's delicious you
can tell she's put a lot of love and
butter butter is your main ingredients
but that's what it's all food is I gotta
say this the sole factor here is is a
full-throttle v oh yeah as a soul food
now connoisseur right there's a lot of
soul in this joint I think it was that
is that the meaning of all souls
community stole his family soul is like
legacy halogen top 3 watch this guy what
have you learned about fall food today
it's really diverse it's really diverse
way more diverse than I think anybody
gives a credit for there's a lot of
things you can call soul yeah